former President Barack Obama and  daughter Malia enjoyed a father-daughter  date night in NYC  [Music]  Barack and Malia attended the Broadway  revival of Arthur Miller's the price in  New York on Friday night the  father/daughter duo were all smiles as  they chatted with the cast backstage  former POTUS seemed to be having a great  time and having a few good laughs with  actors Danny DeVito and Mark Ruffalo and  even took some time to meet and pose  with the crew the former first daughter  rocked a black long-sleeve turtleneck  and matching pants with her hair half up  half down while her dad dressed in a  black suit and white button-down for the  occasion what do you think of this  father-daughter date night let us know  over on Twitter at ET now  [Music]  you